one story that is continuing to alarm
citizens around the country the
mysterious appearance
get this pile of bricks literally being
stationed
near the sites where these protests and
riots ultimately become
they're staging it joining us now to
report on that disturbing story he's in
our west coast bureau tonight
our chief breaking news correspondent
trace gallagher so
they're literally staging weapons and
that they're going to use that evening
to throw the bricks at the cops trace is
that
how we interpret that because that's
what it looks like yeah that's the
belief shot i mean you have these piles
of bricks and rocks showing up as you
said near the various protest sites
in cities like new york kansas city
dallas fayettesville north carolina
and none of the sites are near
construction areas leaving many to
assume
the bricks were planted by outside
agitators specifically to stir up
trouble in fact
the new york police department says it
has evidence that anarchist groups
were pushing the protests toward
violence and vandalism
federal law enforcement officials say
the violence points to far left groups
like antifa
others say far-right groups might also
be involved
and many of the looters don't need to be
supplied with bricks and rocks because
they show up with their own tools in
hand
well prepared to destroy property police
in minneapolis also found caches of
stolen vehicles and incendiary devices
in areas where numerous fires have
broken out and in baltimore there's
evidence of double danger police have
been sweeping the downtown area
after get this finding both bricks and
bottles
with potential accelerants already
inside them but instead of being
left out in the open piles these
potential weapons are kind of being
hidden in small
areas though it's unclear if they are
associated with the protests or
groups on either side of the spectrum
sean all right
trace gallagher thank you for that
report